Hyper ledger and its importance hyper
ledger hyper ledger is an open source
collaborative effort created to advance
cross industry blockchain technologies
it is a global collaboration hosted by
the Linux Foundation including leaders
in finance banking Internet of Things
supply chains manufacturing and
technology it is a framework to create
deploy and maintain block chains for
businesses that ensure accountability
transparency and Trust among business
partners as a result hyper laser makes
business networks in transactions more
efficient concept of hyper ledger now
before I tell what hyper ledger is let
me tell you what hyper ledger isn't
hyper ledger isn't a blockchain a
company or a cryptocurrency hyper ledger
is a software used to create one's own
personalised blockchain service it is
basically a project within the Linux
Foundation just like several other
projects under them which include node J
s all join drone code and a kumo since
it is open source people across the
globe can come and help develop and grow
the platform restrictions in public
blockchain with a goal in mind to
develop an enterprise based blockchain
platform developers started testing
interactions between applications and
secure block chains and realized that
public block chains require each peer to
validate transactions and run consensus
this is a major challenge when it comes
to scalability moreover the transaction
confidentiality and privacy was also
getting lost as every node in the
network was receiving a copy of the
ledger private and confidential
contracts let's consider an example a
certain Bank is giving better privileges
to its premium customers for instance in
credit cards thus if I am a premium
customer of the bank and have been
Banking with them for quite
time then it will give me a better offer
on credit cards or will give me a loan
at discounted rates these things are
common in the banking world however if
these banks start using public
blockchains which have complete
transparency disparity like these will
become evident moreover there is an
issue with regards to competition all
banks are competing with each other in
order to create a better place for
themselves in the market thus they want
their confidential information about
transactions and other operations to
stay completely confidential this won't
be possible in a public blockchain like
aetherium which stores all smart
contracts on public Ledger's this is
where platforms like hyper ledger come
into the picture which permits
permissioned and private transactions
and it is highly scalable as a platform
solution to the restrictions on hyper
ledger network only parties directly
related to the transaction deal are
updated on the ledger thus maintaining
privacy and confidentiality hyper ledger
primarily leverages the concept of
channels to ensure privacy and
confidentiality
a channel is basically a virtual
blockchain network which sits atop a
physical blockchain network and has its
own access rules they employed their own
mechanism for transaction ordering and
thus ensure scalability thereby
permitting effective ordering along with
the separation of data in the above
example when John and Kat are conducting
a transaction a private channel between
them serves as a method of interaction
the smart contract can thus be viewed by
only these two parties and the network's
endorsement policy verifies their
membership with the network to ensure
privacy
thus the transaction is secure and
private and confidential hyper ledger
transaction in the above example John is
initiating a transaction to send a
message to Kat let's assume that we have
a state in the ledger named as message
denoting the last message that had been
sent and its store as a key value here
in peer of organisation now John has
decided to send a new message to Kat and
submit a request to the nodejs back-end
from the message dashboard the node.js
SDK client takes this new proposed state
and sends a proposal to all the
endorsing peers of the organisation as
per the endorsing policy defined in the
channel configuration as well as
confiding to the membership services
this includes a proposal request to
invoke the corresponding function
described in the chain code the message
thus gets verified by the orderer and
finally gets committed to the CouchDB
thus confirming the transaction Linux
family hyper ledger is a part of the
umbrella project under Linux Foundation
where a community of developers work on
open source projects Linux Foundation
provides infrastructure services events
training and financial resources for
creating sustainable open source
ecosystems
linux foundation is known for its open
source projects hyper ledger is a
consortium of organizations it's not a
blockchain platform with hyper ledger
there are different blockchain projects
the original code for these projects was
submitted by various companies like IBM
Intel etc Linux then made these codes
open source to invite the entire
community to work together and
contribute to the codes the vision was
to create an enterprise level blockchain
platform hyper ledger projects hyper
ledger umbrella strategy hyper ledger
nurtures a lot of blockchain frameworks
and technologies under the umbrella
strategy some of the well-known projects
under hyper ledger are as follows
sawtooth Lake hyper ledger sawtooth is a
blockchain platform implementation which
builds deploys and runs distributed
Ledger's it is a modular platform which
provides a digital record without a
central authority or implementation it
is primarily used for supply chain
networks fabric hyper ledger fabrics
framework was contributed by IBM fabric
works as a foundation for developing
applications with a modular architecture
the framework utilizes container
technology to host smart contracts chain
code comprising the systems application
logic one of the examples where it is
used is fishing industry to track the
supply chain of fishes burrow hyper
ledger burrow hosted by the Linux
Foundation is a blockchain framework
implementation the framework was
contributed by Monde ax & Co sponsored
by Intel Borough is a permission smart
contract application engine partially
developed in accordance to the
specifications of aetherium virtual
machine EVM
it is used to run etherium smart
contracts Iroha hyper ledger
Iroha hosted by the linux foundation is
another blockchain platform
implementation the framework was
contributed by Sora Mitsui Hitachi
NTT DATA in colu written in C++ hyper
ledger
Aroha incorporates a unique algorithm on
chain based Byzantine fault tolerant
consensus it provides a small set of
fast commands and queries covering most
common operations for the digital asset
and Identity Management it can be used
in mobile application organization
indeed hyper ledger
in D is a distributed ledger and utility
library built for decentralized identity
the distributed ledger provides tools
libraries and reusable components to
create and use independent digital
identities based on block chains they
are inoperable across administrative
applications domains and any other silo
it is used as a decentralized identity
database Sawtooth hyper ledger Sawtooth
is a blockchain platform built for
enterprise use where the design focuses
on maintaining the safety of smart
contract and the Ledger's are kept
distributed sawtooth offers a simplified
platform for blockchain application
development by separating the
application domain at the core system
level application developers could opt
for a language of their choice to write
smart contracts logic following are some
of the key features of sawtooth
application layer in core system
separation parallel transaction
execution pluggable consensus algorithm
private networks with sawtooth
permissioning features aetherium
contract compatible with seth event
system hyper ledger architecture hyper
ledger blockchain network participants
following are the
front participants within hyper ledger
blockchain blockchain user a blockchain
user performs transaction on the network
the user can invoke a function from the
chain code in order to send the
instruction message to the underlying
network which can then process the
transaction certificate authority
certificate authority ensures that only
certain restricted parties can be a part
of the business network on hyper ledger
they access security certifications in
order to determine the parties who have
required privileges to be an actor on a
network traditional database it is a
standard database which is used to store
data traditional processing platform
it stores access to the logical code
written which is used to run the network
as per the design blockchain development
network it operates the blockchain
network which enables the execution of
smart contracts chain code as well as
various transactions that take place
between the participants which are part
of the network blockchain developer a
developer develops applications on the
blockchain using chain code currently
hyper ledger fabric supports node.js
Java and golang languages to write such
chain codes
regulator regulator runs oversight to
ensure that the platform is operating
without any bias hyper ledger
architecture following are three main
components of hyper ledger membership
service it is a set of cryptographic
materials certificates that defines
organization by itself every peer in
order needs this type of certificate
this certificate has some common
property by which we decide whether the
pier and the orderer
belongs to the same organization or not
a pier which is a part of the same MSP
can communicate with each other a pier
from other organizations cannot be
allowed to communicate with each other
blockchain and transaction layer this
layer constitutes the core code of the
blockchain it comprises of consensus
algorithm which is required to make the
final decision
on the state of every transaction it
also contains the distributed ledger and
ledger storage which stores the entire
history of the transactions and the
last-known States lastly we have the p2p
protocol which is used for communication
between different nodes on the network
chain code it is the logical programming
layer which consists of the business
logic required to run in operation on
the hyper listen'd blockchain and it's
consensus model permissioned blockchain
maintains an access control layer and
allows certain actions to be performed
only by a few identifiable participants
it is also called private blockchain
following are the properties specific to
permission to block chains it has
legally accountable validators it is
suitable for off chain assets they can
be used as an IT tool for settlement and
clearing examples include ripple which
determines roles for a select number of
participants who can act as transaction
validators on their network such block
chains are also popular among industry
level enterprises and businesses
for which security identity and role
definition are important permissioned
versus permissionless blockchain let us
see some differences between a
permission and a permission list
blockchain one in regards to access a
permissioned blockchain only allows
pre-approved members to access the
network and make transactions to it
whereas a permission list blockchain
allows anyone to be a part of the
network as it is completely open and
transparent to permissioned blockchain
are faster than permission list
blockchain when it comes to performance
as they have less number of participants
in the network 3 permissioned blockchain
use different types of consensus
algorithms like pbft proof of stake and
more usually permissionless block chains
rely on proof of work for the
transaction cost in a permissioned
blockchain is lower than that of a
permission list blockchain 5 in regards
to stability permissioned blockchain are
considered more stable compared to
permissionless block chains as the
former have a better governance due to
known parties which are a part of the
network six in a permissionless
blockchain all participants have the
same level of access where as a
permission blockchain provides full
access only to the members which are
registered to be a part of the business
network 7 permission lists block chains
work in a peer-to-peer fashion relying
solely on consensus algorithms to create
a trusted environment however
permissioned block chains have trusted
members as part of the network which
enhances the trust on the network
consensus and it's interaction with
architectural layers consensus consensus
is the process by which a network of
nodes validates the block of
transactions and provide a guaranteed
ordering of transactions and validating
those block of transactions that
to be committed to the ledger consensus
must ensure the following in the network
confirms the correctness of all
transactions in a proposed block
according to endorsement and Consensus
policies agrees on an order and
correctness and hints on the results of
execution depends on smart contract
layer to verify correctness of an
ordered set of transactions in a block
hyper ledger it makes use of the
permissioned voting base consensus from
the pool of the other consensus named
the lottery based consensus consensus
properties consensus must satisfy two
properties to guarantee agreement among
nodes safety and liveness safety means
that each node is guaranteed the same
sequence of inputs and results in the
same output on each node the algorithm
must behave identical to a single node
system that executes each transaction
atomically one at a time
liveness means that each non faulty node
will eventually receive every submitted
transaction assuming that communication
does not fail activities performed to
reach consensus hyper ledger frameworks
reach consensus by performing two
activities transaction or during
transaction validation biologically
separating these activities we ensure
that any hyper ledger framework can work
with any hyper ledger consensus module
the first step of the consensus process
flow is receiving the transactions from
the client application consensus depends
on an ordering service to order
transactions transaction order enables
confidentiality of the transactions it
also increases the efficiency of the
transactions to validate transactions
consensus depends on the smart contract
layer because it contains the business
logic behind what makes a transaction
valid
transaction validation contains business
logic to make the transaction valid it
also ensures the confirmation of
policies and contracts specified for the
transaction then it also checks for
syntax and logic errors consensus model
for permissioned blockchain consensus in
hyper ledger fabric as seen in the image
above is broken out into three phases
endorsement ordering and validation
endorsement is driven by policy eg M out
of n signatures upon which participants
endorse a transaction or during phase
accepts the endorsed transactions and
agrees to the order to be committed on
the ledger validation takes a block of
ordered transactions and validates the
correctness of the results including
checking endorsement policy and double
spending as soon as a new transaction is
created it is sent to the endorsement
peer to generate a readwrite pair the
readwrite pair from every endorser is
then sent to the order ur which orders
the same and generates a block based on
consensus the ordered block is then sent
to the validator to update the couch DB
with the most recent state API and
network topology in hyper ledger API it
enables clients and applications to
interface to the blockchains hyper
ledger supports the following types of
AP is admin ap is this class creates an
administration connection to a hyper
ledger composer runtime the connection
can then be used to deploy Business
Network definitions undeploy business
network definitions update business
network definitions send a ping message
to the runtime to ensure it is running
and correctly configured
story connection profile document in the
connection profile store common api's
they are used to obtain information
about the connected networks this
information can include business network
metadata enum declaration and many more
run-time api's these are used to perform
all transaction operations like running
a query managing assets and more network
topology network topology is a technical
infrastructure that provides smart
contract services and ledger to
applications listed below are the
components of network topology ledger a
leisure consists of two distinct parts a
blockchain and the state database
unlike other Ledger's blockchains are
immutable
in contrast the world state is a
database containing the current value of
the set of key value pairs that have
been added modified or deleted by the
set of validated and committed
transactions in the blockchain smart
contract a smart contract is a code that
is invoked by a client application
external to the blockchain network it
manages access and modifications to a
set of key value pairs in the world
state in hyper ledger fabric smart
contracts are referred to as a chain
code peer nodes it is a network entity
that maintains a ledger and runs chain
code containers in order to perform
read/write operations to the ledger
peers are owned and maintained by
members or during service it is a
defined collective of nodes that orders
transactions into a block the ordering
service exists independent of the peer
processes and orders transactions on a
first-come first-served basis for all
channels on the network channels a
channel is a private blockchain overlay
which allows for data isolation and
confidentiality a channel specific
ledger is shared across the peers in the
channel and transacting parties must be
properly authenticated to a channel in
order to interact with it fabric
certificate authorities hyper ledger
fabric CA is the default certificate
authority component which issues PKI
based search
tickets to network member organizations
and their users the CA issues one root
certificate to each member and one
enrollment certificate to each
authorized user steps to create a hyper
letter following steps should be
followed to create a hyperlink network
is created from the definition of the
consortium including its clients peers
channels and ordering service the
ordering service is the administration
point for the network because it
contains the configuration for the
channel within the network step to
define a consortium a consortium is
comprised of two or more organizations
on the network consortiums are defined
by organizations that have a need for
transacting business with one another
and they must agree to the policies that
govern the network step 3
create a channel for consortium a
channel is a means of communication used
to connect the components of the network
and or the member client applications
step 4 join peers to channels peers are
joined to channels by the organizations
that own them and there can be multiple
peer nodes on channels within the
network
step 5 install smart contracts smart
contract chain code must be installed
and instantiated on a peer in order for
a client application to be able to
invoke the smart contract step 6
optimize the network while there is no
theoretical limit on how big a network
can get as the network grows it is
important to consider design choices
that will help optimize network
throughput stability and resilience step
7
add another consortium definition as
consortium are defined and is added to
the existing channel we must update the
channel configuration by sending a
channel configuration update transaction
to the
or during service step 8 add a new
channel organizations are what form and
join channels and channel configurations
can be amended to add organizations as
the network grows when adding a new
channel to the network channel policies
remain separate from other channels
configured on the same network step 9
add peer and join it to multiple
channels you can continue adding new
peers and connect them to several
channels within the network network
topology the diagram above shows a that
network with the following configuration
there is a fabric network in with
network policy np-1 and ordering service
o channel c1 is governed by channel
policy CP 1 channel c1 has been
established by consortium RA RB channel
c1 is managed by ordering service o and
peers p1 and p2 and client applications
a1 and a2 have been granted permission
to transact on c1 client application a 1
is owned by organization are a
certificate authority CA 1 serves
organization are a peer P 2 maintains
Leger l1 associated with channel C 1 and
L 2 associated with C 2
P R P to makes use of chain code s4 and
s5 the order nodes of ordering service o
are owned by organization Rd hi there if
you like this video subscribe to the
simply learn youtube channel and click
here to watch similar videos to nerd up
and get certified click here